I just want to take a second on my guy
Tyreek Hill saying he's the lion and he
said he got something for me coming off
the edge wait a minute Tyree wait a
minute Tyree I'm letting you know
there's a big difference between me and
those other guys that you coming off the
edge with listen tyreik if you come over
my way and I see you coming my way I'm
sending you to the tent I'm sending you
to the sideline you're gonna say hey
coach I want nothing to do with Michael
Parsons you don't want to do that hey I
already said it once and I said on
social media my baby girl's getting
cheetah print for for Christmas she's
getting cheetah print come over here to
my site with my baby girls getting
cheetah print but all of my guy